so welcome to the the session on the
future of spreadsheets this is an
exciting topic millions and millions of
spreadsheet users around the world and
we know that there's all kinds of
exciting things happening that
technology that will take them forward
so we're gonna start with a four
50-minute sessions from different
speakers and then we're going to follow
that with a panel session and we're
gonna have an opportunity for people a
source of questions just to say this
this session is coordinates by myself
Ben Zorn Andy Gordon who did a lot of
work in this space so thank you Andy and
Xu Han so with that I'm gonna start
right away our first speaker is Selina
Herman's
from Leiden University and Celine has
been doing incredible work with
spreadsheets for many years and so it's
gonna be exciting to hear what she has
to say about the future thank you
Thanks welcome everybody to this session
my name is Felina i'm on twitter as well
so if people are on twitter they can
mention me so I can see if you like my
talk afterwards so I'm here today to
spread the happy word the gospel of my
entire PhD thesis spreadsheets are codes
this is the main important message so if
you still want to switch to another
session that's fine
you have heard the most important thing
spreadsheets are code that's what I've
been trying to convince people for
almost a decade with varying degrees of
success so you might wonder why our
spreadsheets code why do you think that
spreadsheets are a form of programming
well firstly they're used for very
similar problems so what you see here is
a calculation in which you can put some
input it's like a decision model so you
put input then it calculates and it
tells you should we or should we not
give someone a mortgage or something
like this it's very much a problem that
we would view as a programming problem
you could easily build this in Java or
in PHP in a website there are many
programming tools you could use but
people do this in spreadsheets very very
often so you might be aware of the
company Enron that went bankrupt
it's very interesting that their
spreadsheet
as part of an investigation of the US
government became public domain so we
actually analyzed all the spreadsheets
in their email data set and you see that
this type of calculation is very very
common and then you might wonder why
would people do this in the spreadsheet
why wouldn't they just use a real
programming language well turns out we
programmers we're really bad at making
software so we interviewed spreadsheet
users for like why didn't you build this
yourself why didn't you know go to itea
and ask for a system in a programming
language and they're like yeah we did
that and they said it was gonna be 2
million euros and six months and then it
was 10 billion euros and nine months and
it had half of the features all this
wretched I built in one afternoon so it
makes some sense that people use
spreadsheets where you could also
envision a more traditional programming
language so why would you do this in
this range so I go to great lengths to
make my point that spreadsheets are code
to such great lengths in fact that I
built a Turing machine and spreadsheet
formulas only so this is no VBA just
formulas to show that spreadsheets are
turing-complete so what you see here is
one one row is one state of the tape and
then every consecutive row is it is the
next iteration and with conditional
formatting this is the head moving over
the tape so you nicely see the turing
machine so you would imagine that this
convinces people right look it is turing
company it didn't really convince people
although it was it was a really big hit
on the internet and my personal website
was done for a day because it got so
much traffic because people thought it
was hilarious so I had some fun but
people remain remained unconvinced so
again the big story is spreadsheets are
code I hope that the steering machine
has convinced you that spreadsheets are
in fact programming but I'm gonna go
further than that spreadsheets are not
just a programming language they're in
fact the next programming language that
you should absolutely learn because it's
very very exciting programming language
the resistance of spreadsheets is really
really futile
who knows who made this what video this
is wrong Brad Victor yeah as a bread
Victor is a programmer and he envisioned
something called life programming where
would you see here is yours code and
here is the instantiation of that code
and you can change the code and
immediately the visualization updates
you can even change the visualization
and then the code update so it's pure
life programming that he sees as this
big new movement in programming so
that's super awesome and I totally
believe that this is the way to go but
spreadsheets have this spreadsheets our
life programming you just change some
values and then the spreadsheet updates
and it's even so smart and it knows what
you are then and what not to update so
we have live programming which is
something people like what I know also
people that are in programming really
really like is functional programming
functional programming right this is if
we pull something not real programming
then functional programming is actually
real true hardcore programming but
spreadsheets are also functional
programming a formal in a spreadsheet
has never never has side effects
it just takes values for other sides of
the spreadsheet and then calculates the
value of those cells based on the
dependent so it's functional reactive
programming and yet seven hundred and
fifty million people can use it so that
might be a nice goal for Haskell to be
able to approach millions of people and
it's it's really I mean we laugh about
it and I laugh about it but it's really
very interesting that this excel or
spreadsheets in general have been
enabling so many people empowering
people to build their own tools and yet
is not really seen as programming so
here's some interesting statistics there
are and is an estimate of 30 million
professional developers whereas
Microsoft estimates 1.2 billion office
users and of course there are no no
spreadsheet users but a large portion of
that population will be people that at
least know some formulas and
spreadsheets so those
those differences are really really big
and if you look at research effort
that's going into making developer
productivity higher improving
programming in traditional languages and
then you look at the things that people
are doing to improve spreadsheet
programming luckily there are a bunch of
us here meaning together that that's
awesome but if you compare it to how
much effort is being putting into
refactoring and debugging and source
code analysis for a relatively small
proportion then there is something there
that is at least a bit weird so of
course this was more about what
stretches are it's not really about the
future of spreadsheets so I want to show
with you some interesting new work that
I've been doing together with my PhD
student bouncer to improve spreadsheets
because spreadsheets are super cool but
one of the things that we could improve
is this tiny thing right there so the
whole mole of spreadsheets is very much
made as a bane analysis tool that's
probably where people envisioned when
they were designing it they were really
very much focusing on someone that is
entering some data and someone that is
entering tiny formulas like this for a
formula like this it's fine but we have
seen formulas for example in a neural
data set that are nested like 40 levels
of conditional format formulas nested
together or very very complicated
calculation all meshed together in one
formula and sometimes we have even
suspected that maybe if some of that
code was older generated because it was
so complicated but we've also seen
people just may be making those
complicated formulas so this is not very
user friendly and if you look at what a
traditional IDE for textual languages
will offer you in terms of support like
syntax highlighting and automatic
bracket matching auto-completion those
are all things that aren't really there
in that tiny formula bar so that's one
of the things that we want to improve
but we want to step away from the
textual format for like traditional
programming language because of course
there is a new generation of programmers
that is coming and they don't know text
but they've been growing up with
block-based
programming languages so here in who
here in the audience has seen scratch or
blockly or a block based programming
language yes
so we envision that a new generation of
workers that will be professionals soon
will have experienced block based
programming as there may be the first
connection into programming so what we
have built is a tool in which block
based programming is integrated into
excel so you can create your formulas
with a block based programming language
and now I'm gonna show you a few videos
of that yeah so here you see someone
creating a formula with a block base
this is locally by the way a block based
interface if you want to connect it to
the spreadsheet you have to say this is
the cell I want to put it in and you
paste the cell in there you get the cell
and then the function bar has not all
functions yet but the famous formulas
like some and if so you can say this is
where we want to have the formula old
formulas can have a name so that's
something that the Excel model misses
and you see the formula is generated
there so you create the formula here and
then it's updated automatically to the
formula bar so it in the end it is a
traditional spreadsheet so you generate
it with locally but then it is a regular
excel file so if you're a user of our
system Excel blocks but other people are
not you can still share your
spreadsheets because ultimately you just
generate a formula from the blocks so
that was cool but we want to show
something that's a little bit more
powerful because of course the way
people use spreadsheets very often is
they take a formula and they drag it
down that's the way in which there is
abstraction in the spreadsheet platform
but of course this is something that
often goes wrong we've seen that at the
tech showcase as well if you've been at
the spreadsheet corner they're of course
famous examples where people didn't
really change all the formulas in a
proper way so that's the typical
abstraction that we want to improve also
with the block based programming
language so what you can do is you can
select a group of cells and then with
one block create a set of formulas
show you how it looks like on the video
so again you're creating a formula from
here you're saying this is the name of
the formula this is a quarterly total
where am I going to place the formula
outputs you select a range block and you
say that's this is the whole range where
we want that formula to go and then what
do we want to go there a sum and again
we have to select the right column but
now instead of a range we say every
column in this range and I just do
simply select the whole range and you
can put it there so now we've abstracted
over this idea of making a formula in
one place which is sort of weird oh you
put the formula there but actually what
I really want is to have the formula in
all places and then I have to drag it
now you can we think reason more
intuitively this is where all the
formula should go and then at once you
create the formula with the block based
interface but of course we can go a
little bit more interesting than that
maybe some people here are familiar with
the vlookup formula which is a bit of a
weird formula we have a paper about that
as well about the history of the few
lookup because this is how people now
often use a lookup so it is like a join
in a database where you say this is the
ID of the course that I want and this is
the name of the course that's how you
would use it but actually the vlookup
function was designed to do this fuzzy
type matching where you have a range of
scores and then you say oh with an 83
that's in between here so that's gonna
be that one that's how people envision
the vlookup to be used and then people
started to use it as a join and that
means that it the default value if you
do not put a false here in the formula
it will default to this type of lookup
which people now don't use and that
leads to all sorts of misery that you
can read about in that paper that we
that we wrote about this actually so if
you're interested in understanding
issues and and understanding the history
as well you can read this paper but
that's also something we wanted to
address in our new prototype where we
don't want to have this vlookup function
because people have to remember the
function people have to remember the
arguments we want to make something
intuitive or we
say Oh what you really want to do is you
want to look up something that's what
you want to do and it doesn't matter how
it is implement it in the back you know
behind behind the screens so for that we
made a function you see we diverge a bit
more from the functions we say we want
to have a lookup where is the formula
going again this is the output of two
cells where we want the formula to be
generated and now what we actually want
it to look up and you see that these
names of the arguments now really help
the user understand what should go in in
opposed leap locks we want to have a
value for each row what are we going to
look up well that's what we're looking
up and then what is the result what will
we result when we have completed the
lookup that is that so people familiar
with how do if you look up function
works you don't have to say this is the
number of the column you don't have to
you don't have to customize you don't
have to customize exactly how it looks
like and then what happens we generate
secretly in the background and in next
match which is more effective in many
ways and you don't have all the issues
with vlookup so for the user it looks
very intuitive they don't have to
memorize what functions to use if they
need two arguments they are clearly
labeled and in a background we can
generate more interesting or more useful
logic and we have similar things well I
don't have much time and we have more
interesting examples involving
conditionals some ifs and this work is
about to be published in September at V
L HCC and if you're interested in trying
our prototype or exploring it in more
detailed and this has my contact
information so definitely send me an
email if you want to try this out in
your company for an explore where it's
going we're happy to share the prototype
to share the source code with you
because as I said we think a new
generation of professionals is coming
that's gonna be really really
comfortable with this blog based
languages so that's also a little bit my
answer to where's the future
spreadsheets let's both try to employ
raise that textual programming but let's
immediately take the next step to block
base what many people will be familiar
rhythm probably will solve lots of the
issues around
fried cheese maintenance so as we could
set up for the second one if there are
any questions briefly we can we can have
them now any short-term questions yeah
go back here bugging because once you
beaut right that's a super good question
and half an hour ago I wouldn't have had
an answer but I've just seen that the
microvia team is adding in debugger to
their block based interface so we could
take the same approach where they're
really envisioning a true debugger it
has breakpoints and you can step through
the blocks much in a similar way as you
can do with a textual user interface but
we're definitely going to steal that
idea from them okay I think let's thank
Selina again ok so our next speaker is
Dan Bowery from Williams College and
he's gonna be talking about work he's
done on reason about spreadsheets thank
you thanks Ben you guys hear me okay
okay right so I'm gonna talk about some
of the pitfalls of spreadsheets and
really to kind of just two classes there
are many there are many pitfalls but
there's sort of two things I'm going to
focus on primarily I'm gonna start kind
of motivating things the same way as as
Felina I will rely on I won't go into
quite as much details as you covered a
lot of the bases here but you know you
might be wondering why so I'm a you know
a programming languages researcher why
would a programming languages researcher
be interested in something like
spreadsheets well you know if you kind
of look at where these things are used
right you know there's a really huge
audience for spreadsheets and if you
compare that to the number of
professional programmers right let's
assume all of those programmers are
spreadsheet users talking about really a
minuscule fraction of the population
that is actually programming there they
don't think of themselves as programmers
but they are doing some programming
right so the thing is though developing
tools for this audience is
little bit of a challenge because you
know they don't come from us traditional
CS background so how do you report
things like bugs and errors and that
sort of stuff to them and what they're
accustomed to are you know a sort of
intuitive graphical interfaces so if
you're going to develop a debugger for
example you need to give it to them in
some form that makes sense without
having to understand computer science
and really that kind of boils down to
like pointing and clicking on on an
interface right so it's not the kind of
traditional text thing okay so I'm gonna
kind of motivate this with a few bad you
know sort of famously bad spreadsheet
examples here's a this is a earnings
report that that Kodak had it turns out
that there was you know this is a really
tiny mistake somebody accidentally added
some extra zeros to a paycheck but this
is like catastrophic for the company
right here's another one which is even
worse in a way this is fidelity
investments this is essentially a sign
error right they put in you know a plus
when it should have been a minus this
this is pretty bad - and then I I'm
gonna talk a bit about this and I'll
return to this one in a second this is
another spreadsheet that actually came
out of some academic work and this this
one really like actually was sort of
catastrophic in some ways so I'll return
to this in a second okay so what is it
about these have in common it really is
about the data right these were all data
errors right they actually were not
formula errors it was something wrong
with the inputs right and we have a term
in computer science that we use for this
we call it garbage in garbage out right
so you can have a perfectly good program
you give it bad inputs and you're gonna
get bad out outputs okay so this is a
little different than your sort of
traditional program analysis kind of
thing because this nothing wrong with
the program okay
so how do we go about finding that I'm
going to talk about a tool called
checkcell it is designed to help you
find these kinds of problems with your
spreadsheet so what does checkcell do
imagine you have a big spreadsheet and
you it has maybe potential data errors
right and you want to find them right
you want to click on a button and it
shows you where they are and maybe you
get some output that looks like this it
just gives you a ranking of cells that
are that are suspect that you should go
and look at maybe
disorder okay so like I said you know
this has to be an easy-to-use tool it
really should be like one or two buttons
so checkcell is easy to use you also
want it to be precise because if your
tool is not precise users very quickly
lose faith in the tool and they say this
is garbage
right so you want it to be you know
accurate and you want it to be fast and
you know cats are fast rocket cats are
wicked fast right so you want it to be
fast and checkcell is all these things
okay
so what are the challenges in a domain
like this well spreadsheet users like I
said they don't come from a traditional
CS background so they're not writing
specifications for their programs right
also you know the kind of data that they
can put into their spreadsheets it could
be anything right and they're not
telling you what the distribution is
that generated the data right they're
just putting the data in okay so that
means that if you are thinking about
this may be from a statistic standpoint
we were thinking about I'll call you
something like outlier analysis actually
there's no obvious way to map this
problem to let's say a standard you know
closed form for doing some kind of error
analysis in stats so those are some
pretty big challenges right so let me
give you a little example to kind of
follow along with hopefully this is
familiar to to many of you in the
audience here it's just a simple grade
spreadsheet right and I'll let you in on
a secret here are the two errors right
and you know so you know where this is
going and you can see that there's an
output here it's this pass/fail right
and this is grad fail by the way so it's
like 85 is and lower is failing so okay
so let's do a little thought experiment
here let's suppose we were to change in
a value one of those bugs let's say it's
this one it's supposed to be 92 it was
93 what is the effect on the output well
if it turns out it has no effect on the
output you could say this is kind of an
inconsequential error so the insight
here is that if you correct an input
supposing you knew what that error was
and what the correction was supposed to
be and it doesn't matter it doesn't have
more effect on the spreadsheet or it's a
small effect on the other hand if you
fix something that's big let's say this
one here
at the bottom let's say it was a
transposition error supposed to be an 87
instead of a 78 right that actually
flips the outcome of the spreadsheet so
that's a big error right it's kind of a
big impact and so what is the kind of
insight here the insight is the kind of
key insight in check cell is we don't
necessarily know which values are right
or wrong
what we know is which values have big
impacts on the spreadsheet right and if
you want to focus analyst attention on
something in their audit maybe you
should focus them on the things that are
important right so suppose you focus
them on something that's important but
it turns out to be right well okay it's
merely important but if it turns out
that it's wrong right you know kind of
by definition that it's catastrophic
right it's really bad so you really want
to find these these bugs okay so kind of
returning to our example all right let's
suppose we somehow magically found out
what this thing that this was wrong
what would we replace it with right
again we don't know what the
distribution of the inputs was so you
know what would you replace it with if
you had to kind of an automatic bug
finder fix your tool or something you
can't just go sticking random values in
there house has something to do with the
domain right and so the question is how
can we find out that information and the
answer is we can actually leverage this
kind of part of the program this is the
program dependence graph or the data
dependence graph and so what you see
here at the top these little blue things
are the inputs right these are cells and
these little orange things down here are
the programs that compute something with
it and what you know if you look at this
is that there certain cells are treated
in the same way as certain other cells
right they they form a kind of an
equivalence class right and so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna leverage
that equivalence class we're gonna say
it's sort of notwithstanding errors
representative of the kind of things
that we want and so what we're gonna do
is we're gonna run a little experiment
and an equivalence class of two is not
particularly interesting so for the sake
of this talk imagine we have a big
equivalence class that we're looking at
and we think there might be some kind of
error in here and let's say 78 is the
one we think might be wrong what we're
gonna do is we're going to take all the
values from that equivalence class and
resample them with replacement we're
going to compute the function again and
we're going to
save the little value off on the side
all right we're gonna do this a very
large number of times right keep
resampling computing function saving the
output off on the side okay now if you
happen to know something about stats
this is you hopefully in you know
reminds you of something called the
basic bootstrap and what the bootstrap
gets you is a distribution of outputs
with respect to some inputs so you get
something that looks like this for this
particular problem this is close to what
we want but not quite what we wanted to
know is was there an input that caused
something to go wrong so what we can do
is we can condition on this input and
say suppose we left that potentially
problematic input out what was the
effect on that distribution if the
effect on that distribution is rare
right it's probably a bug right and so
so this is kind of how check cell fears
this thing on it's kind of combination
of bootstrapping and conditioning okay
so that's the basic idea
now of course spreadsheets are big lots
of inputs lots of functions how do you
produce a ranking for the total well you
run this experiment for every input with
respect to every function basically if
it's if it if it's weird right if it
looks unusual give it a one if it's not
give it a zero so it's just the outcome
of a binary experiment here you talk
tally these things up and you ranked by
them at the end how am i doing on time
ok great all right and then you just
kind of rank them and you show them by
that by the user to the user at the end
okay so how does this work
this is the spreadsheet I kind of
alluded to in the beginning these are
two Harvard economists named Carmen
Reinhart and Kenneth Rogoff and they
produced a spreadsheet as a part of an
economic paper called growth in the time
of debt it turns out this this was a
highly influential paper that argued
that economic growth is stifled when the
debt to GDP ratio is high okay so how
influential it was used as the sole
evidence for spending cutbacks in 2013
as part of the Republican budget
fortunately did not pass but it was used
to justify the European Union's 2013
austerity measures and that did actually
happen and it went into effect and easie
can imagine this was a very popular
policy right resulted in celebrations in
the streets right and the the kind of
really sad thing about this was that the
analysis was actually fail
flawed right so the question is could we
have found these things using an
automatic tool now there was this really
great analysis that was done by a group
of economists at the same university I
went to and they you know six months
they spent working on this thing hand
auditing the spreadsheet they found a
number of bugs data bugs right so we ran
the tool on the same spreadsheet and we
showed the output to these economists
and it turns out that that's sort of
number one and number two bugs and all
these two that you see here the one on
the left and the one on the right we
actually find those with the with the
tool right so we find the same kinds of
things would have saved them a lot of
time if they had had our tool but they
did their work first so okay so problem
solved unfortunately no there are other
kinds of errors right so here's here's a
few this if you're a scientist that
should really alarm you right here's
another one about the London whale turns
out there was a an Excel error there and
of course I'm gonna return to this one
again and now what what is it about
these ones that they have in common well
in this case it really is not the data
it was actually the formulas so we want
another way to solve this same it's kind
of a similar problem similar setting but
what it's with formulas okay and we have
a kind of a similar input we have a big
spreadsheet
maybe contains a bunch of formula errors
and we want to somehow rank the errors
by their likelihood or something like
that okay so I'm gonna talk about a tool
called excellent that does this and it
surfaces this information two different
ways I'm just briefly going to talk
about this there's something called the
global view which is a visualization and
then there's a tool that uses insights
that we sort of gleaned from the global
view that will tell you which things are
probably wrong okay so here's what it
looks like if you run the global view on
a spreadsheet like this you get a
visualization that looks like this and
what the colors mean is formulas that
are similar have similar color okay so
right away you can see there's something
wrong here these why are these sticking
out right immediately draws your
attention to them okay so it would be
nice to have a tool that can
automatically have these kind of
insights of like this looks weird what's
going on and that's what the second part
does it's called the proposed fix tool
and what it's flagging here is this red
cell is basically saying this is highly
suspicious and it gives you a little bit
of extra information it's suspicious
because it doesn't look like the cells
that are labeled here in green okay all
right so I want to contrast this just
very briefly to what's built into Excel
now so Excel does have a bug finder it
uses this kind of pattern based approach
and everything you see that's labeled
here with green these little green
triangles are errors now I want to point
out that on this spreadsheet every one
of these green things except for one is
actually a false positive right and this
is a problem with a lot of the pattern
based approaches is that they have a
very high false positive rate okay so
again we want it to be easy wanted to be
precise wicked cat fast right and there
are similar kinds of problems right we
have no specifications you know programs
often come with tests we don't have
tests either people don't write tests
for spreadsheets and again there's
nothing obviously wrong there's no
syntax errors right
there's no types or anything like that
that we can sort of give to the user the
program kind of just works so how does
excellent work well here's the the key
insight users don't actually are let's
kind of arrange their spreadsheets
arbitrarily but they're not scattering
formulas all over the place there's kind
of a way that they assemble them and
that way that they assemble them is
actually encouraged by Excel itself
Excel kind of wants you to put things in
rectangular layouts and if you think
about how you use something like some
for example you're gonna sum over a
range and it's easier to use it if
things really are in a column or in a
row so in fact 90% greater than 90% of
spreadsheets that do any computation at
all organize their data rectangular lis
okay so excellent uses this to to to
look for surprising deviations and the
hypothesis here is that surprises are
bugs so to know what's surprising you
have to have a little bit of context
what do we use for context we use this
idea of a layout okay so okay so we have
a working assumption users are not crazy
right and we want to know what was the
layout that they chose so we pick the
least surprising layout that matches
their data and we use this as a model in
order to figure out whether or not
something is a bug
the layout that minimizes the disorder
we use this thing called entropy if
you're not familiar with entropy higher
numbers mean greater disorder or lower
numbers lesser disorder and then what we
do is when we find something that looks
surprising that deviates okay we ask
ourselves this question if we were to
make it look like its neighbors does it
reduce the entropy of the spreadsheet
the answer is yes it's probably a bug
okay so looking briefly at an example it
has to hard to find bugs now you want to
flip it into this kind of mode of what
is the layout of the formulas you can
see the problem right away they just
don't look like the neighbors and in
fact it's kind of suggestive of what the
fix should be you probably want the red
thing to look more like the blue things
than like the green things and the
purple things right it really is the
kind of like the logic is that simple
okay so making these cells look like
their neighbors it the right neighbors
reduces the entropy and if you're kind
of curious about how we do this we have
a kind of vector calculus you can have a
look at the paper so just returning at
the end to this last example here we ran
excellent on that spreadsheet and it
turns out that the number one formula
error that came up in in this analysis
we find right away and what's the
problem with this the thing we highlight
read these cells sum over these things
the things that are in green sum over
these things now the really kind of
hilarious thing about this spreadsheet
is that in fact the green things are the
things that are wrong but we label this
other thing red because in fact most of
the spreadsheet is wrong so anyway
that's how bad this analysis was anyway
in case you're curious you can follow up
on this stuff we have two URLs you can
go to check cell org and excellent org
and thank you
Thanks maybe time for one question okay
alright so the next the next thing we're
gonna have John Campbell principal PM
manager in Excel come and introduce our
next speakers thanks Ben yeah I wanted
to introduce you to the next speaker
before I do that I wanted to say just a
few words about the partnership between
the product team of Microsoft Excel and
Microsoft Research we actually you know
product groups tend to go and sort of
build product fix bugs talk to customers
find requirements sort of drive all that
into the business we rely really heavily
on MSR to sort of be years ahead of
where we are with a cutting-edge
research and sort of some of these ideas
that you know we own the product
psychons that are going to be the magic
underneath the hood for a lot of cases
the partnerships super deep across many
labs and this is just a screenshot of a
few of the projects that we've sort of
brought to life in the product over the
last few years and so you can see this
new feature called data types which are
these compound values that can be in
cells now something that's part of what
we call project yellow and I think
Andy's going to talk about that in a few
minutes
we've got dynamic arrays so this is the
notion of a you know an array of values
as a first-class value that can be in a
Cell ideas is something that we've
released recently that's made sort of a
big splash where you're applying
intelligence to look across columns and
sort of find statistically relevant
information and presented in a visual
way and that's something we been working
with the MSR lab over in China and you
know there's also features that have
been in the product for a while like
flash fill or sort of is this automatic
pattern detection that really sort of
you know generates a program under the
hood and it solves problems for users
like making you know changing inputs or
taking you know existing content that's
in cells and sort of extracting
different bits of it sort of down a
column which is a common scenario for
folks and so I just wanted to sort of
say that we really appreciate the
partnership with MSR you know they're
providing a lot of stuff on the cutting
edge in a space and even right now we're
working with them on you know a
multitude of projects that we want to
ship in the product over just the next
few years and with that I want to hand
it
back over to Andy Gordon great thanks
John
and thanks for coming over and I'd like
to vote for the folks here at faculty
summit like this table at least is some
members of Excel team who've come over
so if you want to chat to those guys
after you know feel free okay I'd like
thanks John I'd like to say a bit about
the collaboration we've had with John's
team on project yellow and I'll give a
bit of a overview of the general
principles we have in project yellow
which are really aligned with what
Felina was talking about very much
thinking about Excel as a programming
language and then I'll have a bit of a
dive into a particular feature that
we've been working on that actually
generalizes some work from people in the
room that I'll come to in a moment
so project yellow our aim is to remove
the glass feeling ceiling that limits
what people can do with Excel and what
do I mean by that well in spite of what
Fleenor stays Excel is actually quite a
crude programming language at the moment
like before yellow you could only have
like numbers of strings in cells and you
know you could do it eration by drag
filling formulas but you couldn't really
do it eration unbounded iteration of the
sort you'd expect to have in a full
programming language so our starting
point really has been two principles one
is to enrich the power of the Excel
functions that you have in the formula
language and find ways to define new
functions using the formulas of Excel
itself and there's an old idea that Mark
Burnett who's sitting there worked on
with Simon Paton Jones at the at our lab
and Alan Blackwell from Kim University
called sheet define functions that
there's been a real inspiration for
project yellow and I'll say a bit more
about that later the second big
principle is on the data side to allow
compound data to certain cells to go
beyond numbers and strings and allow
things like arrays and vectors and even
new domain specific data types to sit in
cells and that really makes it much more
like a programming language you're going
to rich nested data structures and
the first part we can also write fancy
functions that operate over it and
really take excel much closer to the
user
just as in a programming language you
can defined abstractions that are
suitable for a particular situation
you'll be able to do the same thing in
Excel so what is out so far one is a
great one thing is a great feature
called dynamic arrays and I'm Brett
people at that table have been very much
building this and in lots of ways and
what you're seeing there is that a
single formula in a single cell can
denote an array that spills out so in
the let me see and the here you've got
you've got an array here of data
different names and there's a single
formula here equal sort that applies to
the whole array and then this spills out
so you can't do that in Excel beforehand
and this really raises the level of
abstraction about what what you can do
and then this function here is unique so
there's a bunch of names here with some
duplicates and they've been removed and
then over here we're doing some
filtering where we've got a bunch of
people an indication of whether they're
vegetarian or not and then we're
filtering here to get just the
vegetarian so this is really powerful
feature that got announced last year and
and is I'm not sure is it generally
available now just about so so it's it's
a fantastic feature very well received
another thing is called data types or
entities where you can have a record
sitting in a cell that is attached is
basically like a sort of database query
in a cell with the results coming back
and initially these are for geographies
like cities and states and also from a
financial instrument so you can have say
Microsoft would would land as a bit of
data sitting in a cell and you can
extract fields like the name of the CEO
or the stock price and in this this this
image here is showing a bunch of states
and that are in this table so there's an
actual entity there in each of these
cells representing a state and then here
we got some plots that have been
constructed with data obtained behind
the scene so it really means people can
speed up what they can do with with
spreadsheets
so that's really exciting and there's
lots more coming what I want to talk
about now is go a little bit deeper in
this concept called elastic she defined
functions so let me first of all start
off with this paper that I've mentioned
a user-centered approach to functions in
Excel so what is the Sheik defined
function so here's a really baby example
- imagine that we're in a spreadsheet
that doesn't have the average function
but we do have some and count over
ranges let's see if we can code up an
average so we might have a bit of grid
like this where we've got some data five
items there and in this cell here we
compute the count five and this cell we
get the sum 42 and then we do a division
to get the average so that effectively
so the user is able to use the formulas
of Excel to define this computation and
then we've got a bit of UI the lets us
give a name to this average indicate
that this is the input and that's the
output and then the semantics is if we
call this function this new newly
defined sheet defined function what
happens is we make a copy of this bit of
grid and we take an input and we punch
it into this range here and then we
recalc it and then we return the answer
there so it behaves like any other
function that we'd have had in the the
workbook anyway so here's the example
where a set equals average in this case
the same range and it will compute and
and give the same answer but of course
you can apply it to different ranges now
I hate to say we started looking at this
in depth we discover there's a little
bit of a snag with sheet defined
functions as originally defined because
if it turns out that an awful lot of
functions in Excel do actually operate
on on ranges or on arrays and it's
really important that they could act on
variable-length arrays and that's the
problem with the original form of sheet
defined functions so here is this an
alternative view of the formulas in a
grid that makes it look a bit more like
a programming language and that this is
a notation called calc view that we've
implemented that lets you have a sort of
you look at the formulas in two ways to
get more insights so here's the program
and the snag is that if you call average
with say a range that's smaller than
this one well what do you do I mean
maybe you overwrite those three items in
the grid but then you leave these guys
behind and so you probably
get the wrong answer an alternatively if
you gave it a coal with way too many
arguments then probably they they would
they would just get lost and you get
just the average of the first five so
what we really want intuitively
obviously really is you'd like the grid
to spread to match the input and that's
that's exactly what we've implemented
we've come up with an algorithm that can
generalize the formulas basically
picking up on the patterns in a way it's
very similar or it's it's in the same
spirit that's what Dan was talking about
we look at the patterns of formulas and
sort of notice that they are regular and
then stretch them and so in this
calculation we can represent what we
call an elastic SDF which has an
additional length parameters which were
writing in in Greek so average takes an
extra implicit parameter alpha that is
the size of the input array and then the
ranges are written in this slightly
extended notation where this is saying
that the input is in cell b3 down to b2
cell b3 plus alpha for whichever alpha
we've chosen and then we use the same
ranges here to do the calculation and
and the idea is it will it will stretch
let me go on to the next slide to show
that so supposing we have this call here
equals average of this big range there
we the what the function call does is it
figures out that given that the input
ranges of size 200 it's going to have
our sorry no it's not your subside one
nine eight you'll figure that out and
then instantiate this elastic SDF to a
concrete one that has the same that's
let's now had all the alphas eliminated
calc it just like an ordinary SDF return
the result and then discard the
instantiate so that's the basic idea
so here's a more complicated example of
this sort we we put we used in a user
study so here is a time sheet so the
task here is that you've got a number of
employees so one employee per row and
they have a pay rate in this cell here
and then there's a number here of days
that they've worked together with hours
that have worked on each of those days
and at the end here we total up the
number of hours and then calculate the
overall payment and then do the grand
total so we want this sort of timesheet
to sort of
stretch to different data sizes so we
define it as an elastic SDF and then we
can call it say on timesheets like this
and notice that this we've now got a
different number of rules so this this
blue range here is stretchy in the
vertical direction and then this red
range here is stretchy both in the in
the vertical direction and also the
horizontal direction so it has a
different number of days that have been
considered and you do a call like this
and using the algorithm it automatically
stretches so from the users point of
view it's just wonderful
it's really no different from using an
SDF is originally considered they write
their function with fixed size inputs
using familiar copy paste some magic
happens behind the scenes and then the
function works on on the input of
arbitrary size and so that the main
point really of the of the of what we've
done is that we think this will this
automatically inferred elasticity will
really broaden the audience that can use
SDF effectively in a little bit more
detail it's it's if you actually sort of
step to think about it and think about
the the complicated sheets that you can
have it's actually rather tricky and
amazing to us that we managed to do it
to take just a simple concrete example
sheet and then figure out how to
unambiguously generalize it so that it
will work on arbitrary sized input and
so we didn't I should do it and in fact
a cool thing is that it's not just a set
of heuristics we actually come up with a
formal notion of how an elastic SDF
generalizes a concrete one and also had
a sort of ordering over different
generalizations and we can show that
they algorithm given some certain simple
constraint actually finds the most
general SDF that satisfy our last most
general elastic SDF that generalizes the
concrete one we also looked at at how
this worked with users it was pretty
important to us to make sure that this
this sort of cool computer science
actually translated into something that
that people could actually use and that
was really one of the great spirits of
the original SDF paper which was I think
the first paper ever at the
international conference on functional
programming to have a bunch of technical
results and also a kind of theory of why
users would you know end users would
actually find this notation help
so in that spirit we did a user study
well we had 20 users and we we we made
videos that explain how to write elastic
SDS and we did a comparison with the the
sort of courses alternative which is you
would program these SD FS with arrays
and then in order to kind of get the
computations - well we'd use what we
call in functional programming terms
sort of MapReduce style programming
which is what you would do if you're in
Haskell or a very serious functional
programming language so we had a video
that explained how to do that and then
what we found was that they preferred
the elastic SDF to doing in to using
that produce computations and we we use
a standard cognitive workload test to
show that they actually found it easier
to use elastic SDS and we also got some
supposed to feedback that it felt that
elastic SDF were even easier to work
with than Map Reduce you know it was
more in the mental model of Excel you
know you stayed with an Excel workflow
and it was a it was a nice this is
interesting this is more really about
SDS actually that the fact this is
possibly one of the first user studies
with SDS where people found that it was
a nice middle ground you know that you
could you could automate work without
having to go out to something that VBA
or JavaScript which is outside the
normal realm of spreadsheets
I'm just coming to an end my last slide
yes so in summary what we did was an
algorithm to automatically generalized
effectively MapReduce programs by
example that's the effect of it and we
evaluated this both in terms of a
theorem that shows that illustration
yields the most general generalization
and also in terms of a user study where
we found that it was easier for end
users than the the alternative so we
have a paper about this this is
available on our website
a kms and Kyle can tell which is the the
website for our research group and thank
you for your attention
so do we have time for one question for
Andy just a quick question about how you
you kind of instantiate those template
parameters or whatever you call it the
the alpha that you had there
sure can you put is like could you put
in negative coefficients in there right
so like you give an example that starts
with three and now you want to shrink it
down I'm just kind of think of corner
cases what if you give it like an empty
array or something like that like does
it work like this find out the right
semantics or what one limitation is well
your example sort of tile of values has
to have at least one entry in it and and
we so we can go negative we do those
offices are all positive numbers zero no
negative numbers all right and for our
final presentation we have a Xu Han from
Microsoft research in Beijing who's
gonna be talking about some work he's
done on detecting tables and
spreadsheets Thank You van good
afternoon everybody welcome thank you
for coming and please pardon my voice I
just had a 12 hour demo session in the
morning yeah I'm sure Han from the data
knowledge and the intelligence group
msre sure in Beijing so in the past two
years we have been in close
collaboration with excel and together we
shipped ideas in Excel today my topic is
table sense for spreadsheet table
detection which is a piece of work and
technology I will focus on this in the
following in 15 minutes to exemplify our
technology suite in case some of you
didn't come to my demo in the morning so
let's first look at a demo Vedic
spreadsheets are one of the most popular
end-user development tools for data
processing analysis and presentation
automatic detection of tables from
spreadsheets is highly important for
enabling advanced and intelligent
features of spreadsheet tools for
example ideas in Excel empowers people
to understand data through
high level visual summaries trends and
patterns by simply clicking the ideas
button on the Home tab ideas in Excel
will analyze users data and return
interesting visuals about it in a task
pane a key enabling technology behind
such one-click intelligence is automatic
spreadsheet table detection otherwise
users have to carefully select the range
of data to be analyzed
such manual operations would be quite
tedious and time-consuming when table
size is large or when there are multiple
tables on a spreadsheet it can be even
more difficult for mobile scenarios when
small screen size challenges exploration
and interaction against a spreadsheet
furthermore automatic mining against
multiple or mini spreadsheet files
stored in cloud may help generate
insights a long time such insight mining
tasks require automatic table detection
even more due to the lack of data range
selection interactions spreadsheet table
detection is the task of detecting all
tables on a given spreadsheet and
locating their exact ranges respectively
however this task is quite challenging
spreadsheet tables are typically
designed with visual considerations for
easy understanding by human users such
human-friendly characteristics of
spreadsheet tables are quite challenging
for machines table sense is the
technology from Microsoft Research Asia
with high accuracy and high speed in
this case heterogeneous data fields are
created inside tables and the table
structures are complicated alright I
think considering time I will skip the
remaining part of this video already
showed the essential ideas so ideas in
excel adjusted mentioned is a one-click
intelligence but to enable such a
one-click intelligence is never easy
after I click the ideas button we will
go through this bunch of underlying
tasks with great challenges to solve so
that we can enable
the smooth user experience first we need
you to table range detection I will come
back to this very soon because that's
the focus of my talk then for each
detected table we will do automatic
structure recognition as just a
mentioned human users often create some
table with various structure did they
can be very beautiful very human
friendly but it's very difficult for
machine to automatically understand it
and process it so we need to based on
the recognized table structure we need
to transform such kind of human from the
table data into some canonical form the
machine to process and after that we
will then understand the metadata for
example in this five column table three
of them are dimensions two of them are
measures and amount dimensions which
ones are temporal dimension which ones
are categorical for the measures how do
we calculate calculate and aggregate
them for example for sales we usually do
some but for rating we rarely do some we
typically do average all right after the
first three steps we will do analysis
recommendation and in size mining which
may involve a very high computational
complexity or very huge search space not
to mention as well as all the challenges
in modeling the semantics in analysis in
addition to this pipeline we also have a
rich repository of technology suite for
example we also have automatic table
formatting we also have data quality and
defect detection as well as the
automated formula refactoring so today
oh I have then I have ten minutes I will
focus on the table sense for table range
detection this is the problem statement
the input is a matrix of cells and the
output we should detect exact bounding
box of each table as shown in this slide
the red bounding box we need to exclude
the title and footnote and all the extra
parts surrounding a table the technology
I introduced today is inspired and
encouraged by a successful application
of a deep neural network in the computer
vision domain based on this analogy
which is let's compare image and
spreadsheet image is a matrix of cells
while spreadsheet is a matrix of images
matrix of pixels and especially it is a
matrix of cells and we do object
detection in image we do table detection
on spreadsheet we do semantic
segmentation in image we do structure
table structure extraction from
spreadsheet also we do image styling and
we do table formatting so and so forth
so you can easily realize their analogy
however this problem in the spreadsheet
domain has some special challenge the
first challenge I come from the problem
space itself I think
this message has been fully delivered in
the demo video I will not emphasize it
again the second challenge come from
that high difficulty in data labeling
which means for this kind of task the
labeling need to be very precise we need
to precisely label the boundary of
tables but you also realize that in real
world data the boundary of tables and
tables layout they can be very ambiguous
and a label or a human a label or need
to quite often date they need to look
carefully into the data understand the
data and semantics to determine which
part belongs to which table so that's
the high cognitive cost of human
labeling that's one part on the other
side there are a huge number of
spreadsheet files on the internet that
are publicly available but many of them
share similar structure and similar
layout similar patterns with given the
high cognitive cost of human labeling
definitely we don't want to repeat
to label large amount of similar data
points that's a waste of time and effort
so the key is that we need to carefully
select the training data in some system
systematic fashion the third challenge
you come from the high very strict
metric of success let's take the object
detection task in image domain for
example the success metric is usually
defined based on a metric called IOU
intersection over a union and shown on
the right hand side the red box is the
grunt use of a table range and the blue
box is the prediction from the IOU
perspective it's number is over a point
zero point nine it's definitely a
success object detection
however for spreadsheet table detection
it's a failure since whenever we meet
some part of the table especially the
header part we will miss the structure
of the table if we miss some role column
of the records we will have wrong
incorrect calculation result in the
analysis report so in this work we
proposed a very strict metric which is e
OB short for error and boundary u will
be equal to zero means exactly match all
right
introduced the challenges let me come to
the our approach part so in table sense
I will highlight three aspects
corresponding to the previous challenges
first we do sophisticated feature
ization that's more than the RGB and
alpha channels in the image actually on
each single cell there are very rich
information sources so we do very
complex feature ization to capture all
kinds of information on the grid that we
can leverage second we take an active
learning based approach to select the
training data in patches the general
idea is like this at the very beginning
we are somehow the first batch of
training data based on some heuristics
that maximize the diversity
then we treat our first version of table
sense model after that we apply this
version of the model to all the data
that yet to be labeled and then we
select the most uncertain batch of the
data points as the next batch of
training data and then we update the
model in iterative fashion so and so
forth in this iteration one key part is
the confidence model whether we have a
confidence model that tell or this data
point we cannot handle it well or with
high confidence so that's another
highlight of table sense the third part
is it's very important that we add
domain customized optimization target to
our deep neural network model which is
the precise bounding bounding box
regression the general idea is like this
in image domain for object detection
when a bounding box for example we are
detect the class of human body if a
bounding box roughly scoped my position
for example from my shoulder to my feet
then the model of the human body class
can easily recover or fix my dis
bounding box based on the part and the
whole relationship right that is not
true for spreadsheet table in that the
spreadsheet table class is very diverse
quite much much more diverse and also it
is very vague in the part in the whole
relationship
just imagine giving you a local range of
a table it's very difficult to tell
which part of the table it is right so
here in addition to the traditional
bounding box regression we add a module
called precise bounding box regression
PBR and the essential idea here is that
we do regression on the four directions
of each boundary respectively and we
focus on a local local situation around
the boundary rather than part in the
whole relationship another challenge in
the conventional solution is that
last function can be sensitive and
biased to some object sizes for example
you know in image domain most objects
they have they won't have very extreme
aspect ratio or size but for tables that
one table can be very very long and the
aspect ratio can be of a high diamond
dynamic range so in our approach we
propose new a loss function that will
enable more stable gradient that to to
ensure the model training will be
effective so this is the overview of our
table sense model this is this is the
lastest slide about the evaluation the
last line is table sense and other
previous baselines most of them are the
recent state-of-the-art models in object
detection for the object detection task
in the image domain and you can easily
realize advantage of our model and in
other words that without effective
incorporation of domain knowledge even
the best models for object detection
cannot get desirable results accuracy
for this table detection task if you
feel interested you can check out more
detail of our whole bunch of research on
our project website
aka dot ms slash spreadsheet
intelligence thank you okay at this
point I'd like to invite all the
speakers to come up and we'll have a
round of question answering yeah oh yeah
okay and there's a question over here
thanks for the interesting talk I was
curious as to it what are the supposed
advantages of deep learning and CNN's is
you don't have to do feature engineering
and you had a lot of very particular
features for your deep neural net which
looks like it resulted in
good results so I'm curious as to why
the table recognition tasks required so
many features when object recognition of
images doesn't seem to require all those
features to be so that's a very good
question and also I view it as a
insightful question so let's just do a
simple comparison the RGB alpha the
image domain so we usually learn the
visual patterns however spreadsheet
tables it has some visual property but
in addition to that there are many an
invisible part for example our formula
formula if we we can put it this way so
a column of data can be calculated from
the other two columns via some formula
and the formula in this data field will
show some identical pattern and also it
captures the link between this column
and the other two columns and this part
of things is invisible and it's a
domain-specific without this kind of
incorporation of this kind of knowledge
just let the black box model to learn
from very huge number of data it's not
even it's not very efficient or I even
doubt whether it can be effective thank
you
Margaret Burnett Oregon State so yeah
thank you for these awesome talks and
thank you for the little spotlight and
appreciate that I just had a really easy
question about your paper so you
mentioned that it was online and I tried
to find it but all I could find was an
abstract is there a way to get hold of
the actual whole paper the elastic is
yes paper yeah yes it's on if you go to
the publication's if you go to the I kms
calc Intel site yeah there should be a
publication's tab there okay it's it
should be there okay okay and we'll have
we'll have time for more questions but I
think this at this point we're gonna
move this sort of transition into the
panel session and I think the idea with
the panel session is each panelist has
it has one slide is that how it works
and so we'll start with that and then
that'll open up we'll open up the floor
to arbitrary questions so do I just
advance this the idea no I don't need
important things yeah so I think this is
this is a big challenge to make sure
that people see Excel or spreadsheets as
a real programming language because that
is this thing and I think it's even
richer than programming language also
the insights work that we've been seeing
we see Excel as a real data
visualization tool how do we get people
to embrace this and especially of course
not we need we don't need to convince
people in finance but we need to
convince people in programming that this
is a valid thing it's a real programming
language and this is also broader than
just spreadsheets because there are some
other things on this image that I
photoshopped together that are not seen
as real programming like PHP is not real
programming or JavaScript is not real
programming because it's front-ends or C
is not real programming because it isn't
functional we are creating this culture
where everyone is like not real
programming each other and spreadsheets
are just the lowest of lowest of things
but we're definitely not the only one
that received this type of trade
treatments and I think this is really a
challenge
we have managed to convince everyone in
finance the spreadsheets are valid now
how are we going to get people in
software engineering and programming to
also embrace it and really as someone
who has been fighting this fight for
literally a decade I'm super happy to
see so many people are not working on
spreadsheet resurgence it's given me a
new hope okay yeah so I wanted to
highlight this really interesting
article from The New York Times that was
talking about it sort of I guess you can
think of as a time or complexity
analysis of what people do when their
programming and it was really
interesting because if you actually
break down for an example tasks let's
say like data analysis what people
actually spend their time on something
like 50 to 80 percent of the time they
spend is actually not writing the code
but sort of manipulating the data in
order to use it with the code that they
already have let's say R or something
like that and so there's kind of a
variety of names for the tenses kind of
subtasks you have to do before you get
to write a write a program there's like
data wrangling which is like kind of
organizing the spreadsheet structurally
or some let's say data structurally and
then there's data cleaning which is you
know kind of regular lysing the data in
some way dealing with zeros or missing
values and that sort of thing and it
turns out that if you look at a task
like data analysis this is a huge amount
of time it's most of the time that
they're actually spending on this
particular task and so if you actually
then you know let's let's ask how much
time somebody spends actually writing
the code the looks so if you if you're
spending 50 to 80 percent of time doing
the the data wrangling data cleaning
part then that means that 50 to 20
percent 20 to 50 percent is spent
writing the code but actually if you can
kind of further break that down we kind
of know traditionally that people spend
about half of that time conservatively
debugging their code right so writing
new code is actually this almost
minuscule fraction of the amount of
effort that goes into doing something
like a data analysis and this is just
one domain as many domains so the point
of me mentioning this is that you know
if your so what I see is a real
challenge is
if you want to bring spreadsheets into
kind of new domains and you know as
Felina said it's already kind of
accepted in things like finance you
should maybe think about the task like
holistically all right so if you want
journalists for example to be using you
know spreadsheets to do data analysis
you could look at like data gov for
example or there's tons of tons and tons
of data scaling the analysis and you
know giving them the language primitives
are important but they're only a small
part of what you actually need to do so
check cell in some ways was a was an
attempt to kind of address some of these
data quality issues but this is a really
big problem and and I think that if you
think holistically about what you want
to do you know with with spreadsheets I
think it'll kind of lead some really
interesting research dimensions okay to
me so my challenge for the future of
speed shooting is uncertainty so
uncertainty arises a lot in spreadsheets
a lot of the numbers in in spreadsheets
are sort of particularly concerning the
future are sort of predictions and are
uncertain and a present Excel and while
the spreadsheets don't give you a way to
express that uncertainty so we did a
user study we went out and talked to I
think about 20 users and we we initially
solicited you know are people people who
were who had experienced some kind of
uncertainty in building their models in
their spreadsheets and we found that
that estimates which is what I was just
talking about where someone has put a
number an estimate for maybe an interest
rate or the number of sales are going to
have for their product estimates are by
far the commonest kind of uncertainty
that actually arise in people's actual
spreadsheet so I would propose a
principle the principle being that user
a user can mark any cell is being
uncertain so for example they could put
seven plus or minus two put an interval
instead of putting just seven or maybe
put a probability distribution people
should be able to do that on the parts
of the data in a model that are
uncertain and they're not uncertainty to
just propagate through calculation in
the spreadsheet and show up in sales
across the sheet and in tables and in
charts should express that uncertainty I
was totally stoked to meet Matt Kay
yesterday and and look at his slides and
talk with him about visualizing
uncertainty and so we definitely want
the sort of thing that I think Matt's
work it could help support that I've got
up there where before you've got maybe
some predictions of the future where we
just have a line chart but what you
really want is the kind of thing that's
a good banks do they have a sort of
funnel where once you've started at the
future you give some sort of
visualization of the uncertainty and
there's a great PhD that was kind of
overlooked i think like i called
alexander straight back in 2008 and he
based this principle really comes from
him that was something he advocated and
i think we're getting to the point where
spreadsheet technology could actually
implement this kind of vision so i I
hope that will come in the future yeah
this one Peter is a recap of the
pipeline behind ideas in Excel and I
borrowed this page to want to say that
actually some of these tasks and
technologies are at still at a
relatively early stage we addressed part
of it but there are yet well space to be
conquered for example table structure I
still believe that today we are actually
we actually we have seen a lot of
different tables with different
structures I'd like to use the analogy
to a pyramid so at the bottom of the
pyramid is the majority of tables with
relatively relatively simple structure
however when the the level goes up and
up the table structure get more and more
complex
it's very especially for some very
special and the professional domain the
table can be very complex yet today we
didn't seen a very comprehensive
taxonomy of for summarizing this pyramid
of table structures and how to
automatically and and accurately
interpret the table structure and
automatically transform the data into
canonical form so
I would say this party yet still is a
big challenge right thanks a lot I'm
gonna throw out the first question and
then we'll open up the audience but my
first question is what happens to
spreadsheets when we have mobile when we
have voice acting to the interfaces etc
tell tell us about the future of non
desktop mr spreadsheets I mean so
obviously the you know as she mentioned
before the interfaces is already kind of
complicated when you have tables that
exceed the size of your output display
and you know if you're talking about a
mobile device you have a tiny display so
interacting with that I don't know
that's that's tough if you could get
around the fact that you actually need
to click on things right by like
speaking to it obviously that would be
great but but you have all these you
know you have you have a bunch of
complicating issues which is you have to
figure out what's in that table in order
to figure out and you have to figure out
what the person is asking you and they
used to figure out how those two things
need to compose together to come over
there so sorry it seems like a difficult
problem a quick question for all the
panelists how many years before we can
talk to our phone and ask questions
about spreadsheets in a year so I'm a
big advocate for she defined functions I
think she D functions are a great way of
sort of capturing a template you know
reusable budget or a business plan or
whatever and from for the the template
you know what the inputs are and so you
could talk to Cortana you could talk to
your phone and say well what would you
say you know give me a budget and here
are the numbers to put in and you give
the numbers or maybe you and the thing
is it and so the technology you could
recognize what you're asking about and
then pick the SDF that you're wanting to
instantiate and then it you it clearly
see queries for what numbers related to
put in and then it would evaluate the
thing so you're not so with voice you
wouldn't be constructing the spreadsheet
from scratch instead I'd say that voice
is a great way to instantiate bits of
grid and SDF so a great way to bootstrap
that I'm a big fan
yeah an estimate would be hard but I
agree with Annie that the SES are
probably the way that spreadsheet
consumption would be easiest by force
because any layer of abstraction that
you would add where you wouldn't have to
create the formulas but you could simply
reuse them it's probably something
that's gonna ease mobile use them for
use by voice and I'm gonna go with way
more than here
I do like yet the idea of SDS but I
guess the problem then still is also
you're trying to figure out like you
know and obviously there are a can test
that maybe people do all the time and
maybe you could recognize that but again
how do you map that what they're asking
for down to a function it's it seems
like a really again really hard problem
so I'm guessing I'm gonna say like 10
years sure I'd like to add one new
aspect perspective that is presentation
of spreadsheet the table selection
detection is about the one direction the
other direction is how how we better
present it I would view it not that long
I can be sooner actually we have had
some existing discussion for example the
layout of the tables and how to beautify
it for better interpretation with only
very small screen yeah thanks a lot ok
so let's open it up to the audience
anybody have questions so let's sit back
here okay so I have one response or
suggestion and one question which may
actually also be a suggestion and so
first regarding the question where the
Excel is a real programming language I
think this might be a false dichotomy we
should not be asking real versus unreal
programming language maybe we should
talk about excel as a domain-specific
language instead of or comparing it with
a general-purpose languages and that
might add acceptability and makes people
more open to accept that idea then my
real question is there was a lot of talk
about tables and how to identify tables
and in spreadsheets and a lot of use
cases
now if tables are such an important
abstraction for programming with
spreadsheets and they are important to
users which I agree they are well why
don't we give them
and make them available to users like
for example Apple numbers does I mean I
mean well one sort of product answer I'd
say is that I mean say Excel does have
tables you can but you have to think
that the snag is the user has to know
about this and it's very difficult
educate your users to do this you know
you can you can sub select a bit of data
and say ctrl T and then it it turns it
into a table that Excel knows about so
they are there I mean maybe maybe you
should be more discoverable I think this
is a huge challenge that the podium
finds they've you know people are used
to a particular way of operating and
they just don't kind of deviate from it
and so don't tell about the fact that
the table there which means we need all
this machine learning to figure out
where they are so we can you know
generate insights and also one of the
powerful things about Excel or about
spreadsheets is you don't have to design
the table up front it can it can grow
and expand so if you want something then
probably it should also encapsulate it
it should have the same flexibility as
the functions yeah where you add a
column and then spreadsheet knows oh
this is still part of the same table so
the tables that there are now not only
are is the feature no very discoverable
it also doesn't really help the user in
shape the data it gets you more in this
database way of thinking oh I'll first
design my table and it will never change
and adding a column is really an
operation where I say oh I'm adding
metadata cool lines right so just
following up on that that's actually
really nice insight and this is
something that some prior work that Ben
and I did one of the things we found was
that people kind of they actually so
there you know spreadsheet users are not
computer scientists they're not thinking
about data structures they're thinking
they actually kind of think on the
presentation layer right so they think
like what would be really useful for me
to solve whatever problem is I'm trying
to solve I'm gonna lay out the data in
whatever form I think and then as they
realize they need the store more data in
it they kind of you know added or kind
of change it but this is a really ad-hoc
layout and we actually found some really
I mean just kind of mind-blowing
examples where people would construct
histograms for example where the cell is
actually like you know like a pixel in
the histogram and you know it's like how
do you extract the
information the frequency information
from the table you actually have to like
traverse the the table and somehow have
some logic that can do that and you know
this is the downside obviously is if you
want to take a table that has kind of
evolved in that way and do some kind of
automated processing that's problematic
on the other hand it's kind of
empowering that people can do that this
is why they're they're drawn to excel is
that they can actually just evolve their
data storage in this way that solves
this really kind of specific problem so
I I agree with India you have to have
some kind of education component to say
like here's the value of a table kind of
like what we do with you know
undergraduates you know saying that you
should use a data structure other than
an array right because data structures
have specific purposes they just need to
know what they are
hi this is this is actually really
interesting I had no idea about
spreadsheets and research behind it I
was just curious maybe one problem is
that all spreadsheets look more or less
in good you know that infamous
spreadsheet they showed us on the screen
looking at it doesn't look like it's a
terrible spreadsheet right and if you if
you look at code you can say oh yeah
this code looks terrible I just need to
take one quick look at it right so is
there is it I was just wondering how do
you guys start with me well let's make
spreadsheets local course yeah yeah so
actually that visualizer that we did
that was that was the idea was to to
give you some kind of visual signal say
there's something wrong here
but I think you could certainly expand
on this I mean there are so this is like
Ben's favorite thing to tell a crowd of
people about Excel control backtick is
the formula view and it it will hide all
the data and you didn't know so there
you go
and that gets you part of the way but it
actually doesn't bring you to what
you're asking for which is like really
telling me like why is this wrong so
that's that's actually a nice insight
back back I'm hard on Sam it
one of the questions before was beyond
tables what I was going to suggest and
we've done use a map a map is a great
replacement for a table or Co you know
coexisting is a way of displaying
information where you're able to with
the zoom capability you on a map most
time people just have mash ups where
you're zoom in on the map but no you
want to zoom on the actual data and get
more data and we've worked on things
what we call spatial spreadsheets where
the map is the vehicle that replaces the
table and there's a lot of very
interesting things the beauty of the map
is that it will fit the smartphone
because it you know it adjusts to fit
the size and the zoom enables you to do
exactly what you're asking for and I'm
just saying anybody thought about you
know using another platform so we're
saying the map is one alternative
platforms but there could be others as
well I think that you know encouraging
innovation around organizing data etc is
you know in a visual way like you get
with a spreadsheet is a great
opportunity for the academic community
and I have to say I believe it's under
invested I think that's so important and
yet if you think about you know part of
the problem is we have an academic
committee that sort of breaks out into
things like oh here's people doing
programming languages you know code or
here's people doing databases and then
they have schemas and you know and what
you're really talking about is something
you know that's that's a mix but it's
really about you know meeting people's
needs
I'd like to yeah I'd like to add a
comment to this recommendation I think I
can echo that I like the idea of zoom in
zoom out but it's not like the smooth
zoom on the map I'd like to view it like
the level base to zoom so if we can do
level based a zoom we can expose a
different level of details of the
information that that can be make the
spreadsheet more more powerful regarding
presenting information
okay we're gonna we're running out of
time but we'll take a last question okay
great thanks so I'm actually not gonna
ask you a question about uncertainty
because I had a great talk with Andy
about that yesterday and I think
everything you were saying is amazing I
would love to see that happen in Excel
and then think about how to make all the
visualization part work the the thing
I'm really interested in is as you as
you're talking about issues in data
analysis and spreadsheets one of the
things that comes to my mind is issues
in data analysis everywhere else around
the things like replication and
reproducibility seeing things around you
know how you use computational notebooks
and how you make reproducible analyses
like what's the version of that in the
spreadsheet world or how did how does
the spreadsheet world come closer to and
integrate with those notebooks or what
is it like how does replication and
reproducibility work in in that land I'd
love to know or if there's any work on
it or what your thoughts are on how to
tackle that problem because I think it's
a huge and interesting problem
yeah I'm not aware of any work in that
area I can say though that I have tried
to do data analyses in in Excel and you
know if I'm just visualizing the data
it's usually good enough but if I want
to run like a random experiment for
example like say a Monte Carlo
simulation it's just not appropriate for
that and it appears one of the reasons
is that you know data is this like very
important thing in Excel and it's not
really treated to say like a random
variable or something like that and it'd
be nice if there was some kind of
abstraction where I can say like yeah
this is data but it's sort of like think
of it as like a the result of a random
experiment and you know if you look at
tools like are they actually have really
rich tools for doing that kind of thing
and so you know I'll often do the first
pass of a data analysis and in Excel to
get a sense of it but then if I really
want to know competence bounds for
example I'll actually switch over to
something like R so I think you know
there's a really nice opportunity here
to explore data and kind of even get a
sense of things like uncertainty you
know by exploring the data that we just
don't have right now but even in a
simpler sense I mean probably we do our
data analysis elsewhere but most of
fields do analysis and spreadsheets and
then probably the state of the art is
the data graph from Excel
they screen shoulders and face exactly
click like save his image so I would
envision as something like script
ability of that we're either within
Excel or in a separate tool you could
say this is my data I'm taking a
snapshot of the data and how it ends up
in the paper is I ran this so that you
could have a replication package that
includes a spreadsheet and a little
script of what picture exactly you are
putting in your paper I actually think
that would be a very great extension
that would help in a similar way that
you have Mitter for R where you can have
lots of codes and that just put your
picture right in your paper and you can
regenerate to pay for anytime I think
they'll be super valuable for
spreadsheets as well so I'll use this as
an opportunity to make a plug for
something called the fluid framework
which was announced at Build it's a
Microsoft technology but I believe it's
open source and it basically it's is you
can think about it is sort of objects
with collaboration at the bottom so it
makes it very easy for multiple people
to edit and to share artifacts including
documents etc and I think with that
we've run over time I really appreciate
your your attention and yeah so thank
you very much
[Applause]